they look picturesque out here in the
Welsh Countryside but cows produce so
much gas
they've been calls for years to reduce
livestock farming
but now a possible breakthrough in the
form of a flower adding extracts from
daffodils to animal feed could
significantly reduce the amount of
methane cows produce
on his farm in Palace Kevin Stevens
breeds cattle and grows daffodils and
has been part of the team developing the
idea
there are governments across the world
currently
um
trying to meet the Net Zero targets by
either taxing livestock Farmers or
putting quotas on the number of
livestock you can have because of this
methane byproduct this gives us a very
real opportunity to actually change that
whole story
this Farm will be one of several where a
feed containing daffodil extracts will
be trialled
initial lab-based tests have proven
extremely promising the hope is if it
works in real cows this could be a game
changer for farming
it's estimated that half of the
country's methane emissions come from
cows and livestock produce around 14 of
the world's greenhouse gases lab tests
showed that daffodils reduced methane in
artificial cow stomachs by 96
so scientists hope that feeding
daffodils to cows could reduce emissions
by at least 30 percent
they're now beginning a four-year trial
to establish how effective it is
this is vitally important because we
need to reduce the production of
greenhouse gases from agriculture as
part of the solution to reducing the
problems of global warming
their beauty famously captivated the
poet Wordsworth but few would have
thought a host of golden daffodils could
help scientists solve the pressing issue
of how to farm sustainably into the
future Becky Johnson Sky News Palace